cette norme les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
tab à 3
la femme que j'aime n'est pas celle que
je croyais ou bien elle ne l'est plus en
tout cas quelque chose a changé dans son
comportement
par exemple elle prend du plaisir à
jouer au golf alors que je n'y joue pas
moi même
je trouve extrêmement vulgaire cette
façon brutale de lancer le cochonnet
qu'un bâton
et bien elles mêmes ça
il me semble qu'elle fait preuve d'un
certain manque d'élégance de coeur en
étant heureux sans moi non
j'ai malheureusement eu la confirmation
fulgurante de son égoïsme pas plus tard
que la nuit dernière
nous étions couchés tard elle dormait
profondément
vers 4 heures du matin je me sens et
train par une sourde angoisse
sur aux tempes gorge sèche
je bondis aujourd'hui j'ouvre à la volée
la porte de la chambre et je me retrouve
au coeur d'une mer de sable en un pays
brûlant près d'un cactus mort je vois un
homme en tenue militaire de parade me
semble-t-il je vois cet homme s'enfoncer
dans les sables mouvants
et de cet homme seul la tête et les bras
galonnés émerge encore de la boue cette
espèce de boue sèche
et cet homme je le reconnais je revoie
sa silhouette immense qui les dépassait
tout ou marches des palais des rois du
monde où l'on écoutait sa parole quéré
j'essaie en vain de crier son nom je
suis muet pire je suis à trois pas de
lui qui sombre et je ne l'êtes pas comme
si des liens invisibles mme rivet les
bras au corps et qu'est ce que je fous
dans ce cauchemar
j'essaie de bouger mes doigts engourdis
ce qu'il touche et soyeux c'est le drap
de satin du lit conjugal
je rêvais
l'instant d'après assis dans le lit la
tête dans les mains j'essaie
d'interpréter ce songe étrange alors que
la boule d'angoissé toujours là malgré
leur assurant de certitudes de l'armoire
à glace trapu ou j'entrevois mais regard
affolé sous ma tignasse hirsute ces
sables mouvants ne symbolise at-il pas
l'oubli
7 qu on exhibait naguère encore à la une
des gazettes n'était-il pas en train de
sombrer dans les instables profondeur de
l'oubli aspiré dans le noir no man's
land des mémoires mortes ou
l'ingratitude des peuples en fuite a
jamais les héros d'hier quand d'autres
héros se lève et les ensevelisse à
l'ombre formidable de leur gloire
nouvelle
ainsi m'expliquer ce rêve pesant
c'était ça j'en étais sûr
mais elle elle qui dormait là près de
moi elle avec qui depuis si longtemps je
partageais sans compter mais moindre
émotion elle qui connaissait tous des
parties de moi que je ne lui cachait pas
elle que je savais faire profiter de mes
moindres souffrance ou poids vue que
s'ils jouent enflait quand j'avais mal
aux dents elle qui en somme était si
proche de moi comment elle est l
interpréter mon rêve
pour l'heure elle continuer de dormir
près de moi d'un profond sommeil
d'enfants je la réveillait d'un léger
coup de genou dans les seins
ne trouves tu pas lui dis-je tête depuis
quelques temps on ne parle plus beaucoup
du duc d'edimbourg
sa réaction m'a déplu à coup ça m'est
égal ce sommet s'il te plaît laisse moi
dormir
on n'est pas plus égoïste non
il ya comme ça des gens qu'on aime
depuis vingt ans et que l'on croit bien
connaître et puis un beau jour une
triste nuit c'est c'est la déception
brutalement la lumière d'un drame humain
pas nécessairement lié directement au
couple comme cet étrange silence qui
pèse autour de la personne du duc
d'edimbourg on s'aperçoit qu'on a vécu
tout ce temps auprès d'une étrangère
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas j'en ai marre de dire toujours
c'est pas pour capter pour rien qu'ils
me virent dans les campagnes trouve
autre chose
[Musique]
fait peu non